[Applause]
[Music]
welcome everyone to hawaii
i have great news first of all very
important news as
you guys know tambourine died i mean
rest in peace floor gang tambourine this
is so sad
however don't cry yet flargan tambourine
has been under surgery
for the past 100 hours and it looks like
she has recovered slowly floor gang
tambourine
is out of surgery and look at the
results
it was a successful
how do i fix the tambourine i don't know
all right let's get into the memes
leave your entries in the subreddit
and i'll watch submissions in the next
episode
and we're only halfway through the year
oh god
you would say in movies when there's a
war usa in movies when there's a virus
outbreak
you say in real life when there's both
war and a virus outbreak
usa be like burra same as tambourine
basically
yes i've been wearing the same shirt for
three days straight now
i'm sorry i'm disgusting i know i'm
supposed to work out later
and then i'll shower i promise okay side
is now editing our videos
sai pewdiepie channel mr b's channel
so if you missed one upload tambourine
is going to happen to you
read the thirst september editors
when marzia comes on stream queen marcia
oh my god i love her so much
big peepee and that's a fact damn that's
some next level simping
guys we have now also tears on the floor
gang members
we have a discord very epic for members
only
and on tier three you get access to only
my only fans account
check it out peters talks so much
english that he has an
english accent now when he speaks sweet
no
no they are in there
who brought that man friends
oh god so embarrassing talking to my
parents now and i just
speak wrong words all the time all the
time in all languages
i suck at all languages now thank you
black woman calls you sugar
all the white man calls you son southern
woman calls you honey
british woman calls you love swedish man
calls huge baby
who's me [ __ ] also if you remember
automatically huge pp just throwing that
out there all the membership goes to
charity
just throwing that out there companies
during pride month
why are you gay money i heard somewhere
that gaming companies they changed their
uh i don't know if this is true but i i
saw somewhere that they changed
their company flags to to rainbow in all
their different twitter accounts but not
russia and middle east
then what's the point which kind of
confirms is me
am i right when you spend 4 20 69 and i
didn't even see i'm sorry i'm sorry
i see it now that's the biggest pee-pee
i've ever seen in my life huge
uh that was at the start of the older
donations they were happening so fast
thank you so much to everyone that
donate we raise for those who don't know
we raised 116 000
to charity last live stream amazing i'm
so proud of you guys it was so great
everyone was simply to marzia we played
rocket league
we played terraria it was epic piers be
like 104 million youtube subscribers
20 million instagram for lovers
followers
13k reddit karma is that a lot i don't
even know
i don't understand reddit i go there
every day but i don't get it
george floyd's smiling daughter six says
daddy changed the world
ah i didn't know he had a daughter
on may 27th 2019 pewte tweeted asking
for video suggestions
the most like reply would win let's take
a moment to thank the man who made it
hope possible
dr grande oh yeah right he i forgot he
knows doctor
i don't is he a doctor in 2020 pewdiepie
changed his camera
in 1999 japan redesigned its flag
boom i like it better before i didn't
change my camera oh wait i have frame
now i didn't realize it's supposed to be
for the streams
guys massive improvement on the videos
and yes i have pillow i got back issues
now
i thank you very much floor gang is
worth it though
100 you have to buy my chair it's 399
and it's really comfortable so you can
become a great fantastic did i say that
a great fantastic
if i buy your chair what will happen to
you where will you
you're about two years too early good
meme here we are
i killed skeletons i survived multiple
creep for explosion
i escaped death itself i smack
tambourine
well a little too hard i think edgar was
you know it's kind of like opening a jar
when you do all the work and then
someone opens the like the last bit
that's that with a tambourine tambourine
will be healed
it doesn't heal it works 99 of the time
i don't understand
someone was suspect put a curse damn is
that
it's naturex i recognize it amazing
i'll see you soon my man i feel my heart
crack now that we have a discord we were
talking about
doing like a private uh minecraft server
and stuff like that for tier three
members
tier three also gets only fans account
i'm just saying
the whole world fighting corona racism
ebola
pewdiepie fighting coco melon subscribe
all right we have the new intro did you
roll the entry outside do it now
[Music]
i love that intro joji joji fancy frank
oh my god i get it now because we're
watching finishing firms on the
live streams uh a positive article about
pewdiepie
despite his races fast
we cannot ignore all of these old things
that happened years ago
that he clearly doesn't do anymore okay
felix donates 10k and raises 100k for
charity media
i'm gonna pretend i didn't see that i
think i saw some articles for it so
credit word credits do artist creates a
fan art
some random guy our fan art no i'm just
reposting it in case he doesn't see it
i'm not taking credit
but he's about to give me ready go wait
there's gold on reddit
gold let's get go oh
pewds english in philosophy videos
appears english in his other videos
yeah because they're scripted out and i
can think and now i'm when i think
it's not good they have a petition for
felix to do a whole
video in swedish and subtitle it to
english
i i looked
i swear i can't speak swedish okay it's
just weird to do it in a video
uh roses are red christ is green never
underestimate
the power of i can't say the word with
tambourine
wait does that make me
my pp irl might be a connector felix
remix i'm just kidding
how girls treat each other you are cute
i like you
how boys treat each other jack's an
a-hole i hate him
irish [ __ ] made with no friends i'm 30
and i never even washed my knees
19 year olds but how can you wash them
if they don't exist
how do i wash t-shirt that clearly
stained and smell i smell bad
it's okay just pretend i smell like
roses and leaves
imagine if all their shirts said 69 that
would be
amazing 13 plus 33 plus
that's the biggest pee pee i've seen in
my life my life hey i got what are you
doing here
what's up homie you're here to smack the
tambourine you have to smack the
tambourine
hit it you want to sit in my lap
yeah what do you want felix's behavior
shifting between acting like a caveman
and philosophizing about life paco
paco yeah i don't get what's wrong with
me either trust me i have no idea
oh my god oh learned a lot of japanese
oh
oh a lot of great things from our japan
trip why is this intro i always do this
i was thinking between you and edgar and
i decided last minute
thank you now we're about to get married
so why don't we do a test and do it to
see
if we are compatible to get married or
not probably not
so this is from marriage.com i don't
know why i say it like they're sponsored
jesus christ
what are your expectations stop it how
much
of the time do you feel happy with the
person
rarely
[Laughter]
i can't watch this goddamn small pp
small pee pee i still get big
because impressive but small pp in here
i hope you understand what that means
that's way harsher
when you edit h p into your meme society
no no stop it
hell yeah hell yeah that's that's a wall
gang right there wall gang
wait what is this oh hell yeah
oh hell yeah oh my
hey
[Music]
yes
pewdiepie's yo-yo bizarre adventure epic
that's a
master pp super impressive made by bag
store belongs in a museum
god damn amazing pewdiepie versus coke
melon pewds releases a diss track again
so coco melon responds with the nursery
rhyme against pits
oh careful what you wish for we need to
infiltrate
the minds of children let's get it boys
i mean kids oh god big ad after watching
pewds workout review
let's get it big ed big ed floor again
question mark
let's get it 19 year olds pewds workout
review
it's gonna get buff as hell let's get it
20 muscle increase
subscribe right now and defeat coco
melon i can't believe i didn't show tom
and jerry in my
nostalgia video that was so good
remember to take it easy once you start
working out i forgot to mention that in
my video
uh join the channel to get access to
members only content like this video
another exclusive prank let me
have it just gotta catch it live bros
come on
become member huge pp felix shouldn't be
embarrassed that he's
177. i'm not 177 i'm 179.
i'm 100 positive every time i measure
i'm 179 and then i joke that i'm 180
as a meme and then everyone's like oh
actually he's 175.
like what the f because that means he's
69 inches tall
i'm 179 confirmed every time i measure
myself
i'm one on two stage i do leg
everywhere
big bp metaphysical leg exercise
you gotta do it you can't skip like oh
you can't skip leg day no matter what no
excuses
all kids in future trying to learn all
things happened in 2020 for their
history final
ah oh poor kids in
first grade teacher it's story time the
class
what small peepee i don't get it
pewdiepie um what you got there brad
i found with every single bad thing
pewds ever said that had to be edited
out that can be used to blackmail him a
smoothie
no we would always joke about this be
like oh no
listen i don't say bad stuff in my
videos scythe can confirm right now and
she will
say thank you shy what is this italian
woman attacks
vulnerable swedish man
what circa world war one hi mimi how
does a zoom prom sound to you
my girlfriend's been watching period
since 2013 help a broad
get this on the y
say no mimi say no she he's got small pp
look small pp i'm kidding huge say yes
he's got huge pp i can confirm that it
creepy huge mimi
i just made it very uncomfortable for
you to hope you enjoy that
uh appears after beatboxing for two
seconds so i remix that
and make it into a hip-hop single back
then brad edit something cool here
brad no the contrast
you know what i like both but thank you
scythe very cool we appreciate you
felix and pewdiepie should do a
collaboration oh my god that's a good
idea
that's really good idea i'll have to ask
obviously he's very busy
trying to save the world raising money
for charity curing cancer
but i'll ask you know he's so humble i'm
sure he's gonna
say something brother i don't feel so
good hang in there buddy we can't be a
dead meme
he even killed ricardo we have no chance
against him i didn't kill the main
shut up small peepee i did not kill the
me when you want to buy a pewdiepie
hoodie but you see your
whole saturday written on his price poor
gengo
join wealth gang right now ow membership
ow
access to discord ow member chit chat
only
we need a little mask me with too much
time and wanting to become a graphic
designer my time has come
so i've already got it yeah i'm sorry
makes 2012 meme
like pewdiepie said gets negative karma
and banned from ready
got him small peepee by the way that's
amazing
cool art my dad read this i hope you
like it huge peepee day
you dagger huge peepee when you hear
that jake paul is in jail
thomas has never seen this good before
uh no he didn't go to jail but he will
get
charged and i think this is a great
example of uh
even if you are part of a group that's
doing something illegal you are
complicit by just being there
don't forget that jake paul should
really know better
nice all right we i post videos early
for members as well
in case what you aren't convinced yet
you get videos early
greek mythology greek mythology if zeus
and poseidon didn't freak random cute
girl
wait what does that reference i thought
i knew greek mythology
there will only be a few lines if you're
an instant of freakish mom
rn we got percy jackson because poseidon
freak
it's percy jackson when your meme gets
into hawaii but pewds damage it i fear
my peepee
it's shrink big peepee
it is now normal sized normal size pp
normal size i'm so glad i grew up
watching this
yes tom and jerry was a sh and not this
cocoa melon bad cucumber bad we want to
do a cocoa melon
and then i take shower after god i look
disgusting
1989 it's amazing to think what great
and exciting things people will be doing
with pizzas in 30 years
nothing will stop glorious creepy tower
top peep repeater tower nothing good
gloria
[Music]
tower
has bigger pp interesting
[Laughter]
thank you for watching
that's a 2016 meme oh my bugs are so
cute
i guess laying on my uh egg it just
farted
shane tambourine of sheamus guy oh he
looks scared sorry girl but don't fart
why this baby from nevada is obsessed
with floors
i will watch your career with great
interest
my brother who knows how to beat the
boss at that one game
me very epic nice new meme template very
nice
whoa that's pretty dope titanium it's in
titanium that's so cool
[Laughter]
pretty much pretty much stop him
i see no gamer up here other than me
i'm above the ceilings and the floors
i'm ascended join floor gang and ascend
all above
the house for my english class i have to
make a task about pills
now i finally have some respect for my
book what
i mean a book watch the interview with
youtube star felix shelburg and also
known as pewdiepie then read their
sentences
and take whatever whether they are true
or false also correct their false
statement
pewdiepie has about 10 million
subscribers false
i have a hundred mil pewdiepie is well
known for his entertainment vlogs
commentaries
on video games i see playing true i'm
epic
pewdiepie meets his fans almost weekly
false i don't leave my house
people often put advertisement in the
comments of youtube videos
true it's very annoying stop it small pp
pewdiepie owes his success to a lot of
hard work and some luck
true at least i would say so consistent
floor game
oh consistent pewdiepie became a popular
worldwide because he played call of duty
in his videos
false no one watched that until today
that's funny coco maryland
subscribe actual nine year olds please
we need the actual 90 year olds
pewdiepie minecraft dungeons terraria
we're playing terraria right now i hope
if i have time today i can
stream some me hit my friend in
minecraft his 64
dogs so you have chosen dan that's
amazing
very cute very cute huge pp image and
huge ppr
that's all i gotta say putting
pewdiepie's face on different people
don't do that someone flagged this as
this is misinformation
jesus christ who reports reddit post
cringe
uh robin hood sails from the rich gives
to the poor jake paul steals from the
poor
and keeps for himself even though he's
rich
no he's just an idiot that's it uh
whatever the frick is going on in pitt's
video
cyber secretly sneaking pair the pla
what what is this i don't get it
say you know what happened to tambourine
you know what happened to it
100 hour surgery felix with his shirt on
felix shirt off
oh yeah it's not a real relationship
if you haven't met irl demonstrator 64.
no no oh wow
that's a cool one dude if we can get
this animated
please calling all anime bros that's
really cool though
big peepee hey look at that just jared
be like okay
fine okay fine i like knowledge i'm
proud of you guys
thank you so much for helping and screw
his stinky floor gang i don't really
like the color green
bill of shame temporarily
very nice
[Laughter]
wash your needs oh dude i need that
melon helmet i need to buy a melon 69
minutes oh epic
that's a lot of minutes
i'm beginning to see a pattern here that
i'm not so sure i like
i made this art and i want to post it on
the pewdiepie subreddit but i can't can
someone who
got a lot of karma posted there it is
big pp
that's dope about two late days late but
someone needs
to tell felix asap 90 pounds
wait a minute
it does have a problem which is that if
i want to make a jump
it's a high jump to go from 80 to 90
pounds
80 to 90 pounds like 10 pound increments
oh no these things don't go in five
pound increments
really i don't know i could have sworn
oh wait that's ten pounds hold on
wait what are these what
it's almost like these tubes here
[Music]
what can be removed what
from the handle oh my god and like
how much do you think they weigh
oh i had no idea
that's really useful
don't appreciate the sarcastic tone but
thank you so much that's super helpful
actually
two things consistent an idiot and floor
gang told you
how do i know damn i can finally go
higher weights now
jake paul drops the soap
ha ha nine year olds to side now nine
year olds when brad was the editor you
[ __ ] talking
don't even get me started on uh michael
me refusing to eat my food until i found
the right video to watch
me my fur big baby made me laugh
very good hey
when pewdiepie turns rtx on no
no there he is we won mr stark
we won yes who's gonna tell him
[Laughter]
oh it's my own headphones someone told
me on the live stream
thank you live stream bros all right
that's the end of the y
i'm gonna go increase muscle size 20
hope you guys enjoyed this episode if
you episode yeah episode if you enjoyed
subscribe we're trying to beat coco
melon to assert dominance
once again and return this channel to
its old glorious form
coco melon if you don't want jam this
track might come
you can join floor gang memberships now
floor again tier one gets the access to
badges
and emojis and community posts floor
gang tier two
you get all of the rest plus exclusive
access to all the old live streams
membership only chat floor gang discord
access
vlogging t3 gets exclusive floor gang
only live streams shout out in videos at
the end of the outro
gameplay with you guys and early access
to new videos
thank you for watching see you guys
tomorrow bye bye
children of nine parts
it's time to raise what was once
forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
poop dear's coming to
nintendo switch
and remember it has a very big pvp
pre-order promotion i mean
[Music]